wenn sie keine probleme im magen haben
können sie auch rechner ich würde
betroffenen
initiativen betroffene einladen ins
schloss bellevue ich würde auch im
winter
zelte aufstellen und schauen ob nicht
räume auch im schloss bellevue noch für
menschen die auf der straße leben in
berlin zur verfügung gestellt werden
können also ich würde schon versuchen
ganz klar den den kontakt den dialog mit
betroffenen zu suchen von ihnen zu hören
was wichtig ist ihrer meinung nach denn
betroffene sind die kompetenten für ihre
lebenssituation
ich würde auch endlos einladen die sich
für geflüchtete menschen engagieren
mit der lunge der präsident
präsentiert präsentiert deutschland also
es ist mehr
ein amt was nicht unbedingt
entscheidungen treffen kann aber man
kann den fokus der öffentlichen
diskussion schon auf themen
konzentrieren ja das thema armut es gibt
13 4 millionen von einkommensarmut
betroffene menschen arme menschen
sterben deutlich früher frauen 4,4
männer 8,6 jahre früher
alleinerziehende in der regel mütter
sind zu 40 prozent von einkommensarmut
betroffen
jeder fünfte schwer behinderte mensch
ist von armut betroffen und das sind
doch alles fehlentwicklungen und genau
das möchte ich noch vehementer auch der
der politik vermitteln den
entscheidungsträgern hier muss gehandelt
werden
okay und ich sagen einfach komplett
alle parteien haben sich schon fast also
fast alle parteien auf steinmeier
festgelegt und ja schon von daher habe
ich keine reellen chancen aber ich will
diese nicht vorhandene chance dennoch
nutzen um darauf hinzuweisen dass schon
etwas in unserer gesellschaft sich viel
entwickelt da ich würde auch als
bundespräsident mit dem arztmobil nicht
mehr so häufig wie jetzt weiter
verantwortung der nicht